what we didn't even get to Taylor Swift
are you kidding me are you a Swifty are
you
if I if I was known for anything I'd
rather be known for being a Swifty than
any of my events I've ever done so blend
cold wine Ludwig yeah rather than
stealing all of my boyfriend's money
yeah I was explaining to someone because
Kelsey's a huge Taylor Swift fan so I
was like explaining to another guy the
other day like what it is about Taylor
Swift that the fans of her are so
explaining it well yeah I was like I was
like I understand it now like now that I
I'm dating a huge fan like I get it I
never got it before I was like Taylor
Swift like she's just like just an
artist and now hearing Kelsey like tell
me what she means to her I totally
understand it now but I want to hear you
no I want to hear you mansplain it real
quick wait man explain go ahead man I
don't think I meant to explain I want
you to explain your girlfriend's
feelings about Taylor Swift
no you can you can you can I came up so
much like I have this really bad issue
with my tone where I sound so [ __ ]
mean yeah I wasn't trying to be like
condescending right now
yes I I know I'm saying like I
understand it and I get where she's I
want to hear I do want to hear how you
understand it I really do first of all I
think her lyrics
are
they're like just very applicable and
they I think like for people like Kelsey
she grew up with Taylor Swift and every
album and every song kind of just
described her moment in life perfectly
to have someone like that and an artist
like that that is continuously making
stuff that represents your life now to
listen to that stuff it's like totally
nostalgic and it just makes you it just
like time warps you back to that moment
yeah like she's really good at like
making lyrics that are that just like
make you feel things that aren't too
abstract you know what I'm saying yeah
did I nail it you nailed it you nailed
it now I have to with that mansplaining
no it wasn't it wasn't man swing I'm
trying to like I actually genuinely
appreciate her like Artistry now wow I
thought this is this is a flaw on me I
thought you going into that was being
very sarcastic no which was why I was
like this [ __ ]
yeah no I was actually like some guy
because I was talking to some dude and
he was like yeah right man come on like
it's Taylor Swift and I was like no I
get it now yeah I understand it's like I
don't I mean for me I'm sorry when you
were like her lyrics I fully thought the
next few words gonna be like are for
girls
here we go that's where I was at this is
I was like all right let me hear it yeah
her lyrics are like definitely for women
but like in a cool way
yeah my my dog who was 11 years old is
named Swift after Taylor Swift okay
that's how in love with this woman that
I am are you you're not laughing at that
you're choking I'm laughing at Taylor so
good don't think about it
um sorry no yeah his name's Swift my
dog's name is Swift after Taylor and
Taylor Swift has her songs I sound like
such a girl right now her songs aren't
just like songs they're legitimately
stories so it's like when she has a new
album come out it's like your favorite
book has a sequel yeah you're like [ __ ]
yeah like what are the stories she's
gonna tell us this time because there is
so much more especially now that she's
like grown as artists she's not just
writing about her experiences anymore
there's in her last two albums there's
like this set of people that she's wrote
a whole storyline about and it's so cool
to listen to the song and then be like
oh that's that's person perspective or
that's this person's perspective and and
the way she uses words to explain
someone's gonna [ __ ] dunk on me in
the comments about this just because
they're gonna be like typical white girl
yeah
but genuinely like she's really really
good at storytelling and there's the
lines from her songs that I'll be like
oh [ __ ] like that was a good way to put
that there's no other way I could have
articulated that you know it's a good
Storyteller as well as Kanye shut the
[ __ ] up Kanye is a good Storyteller he's
so good his his Instagram right and like
where is he right now
I was like wondering what is he up to
what would you do if he just walked
through that door well we have a
surprise I would say we need to talk
I wonder
damn someone still has a significant
other
yeah you definitely were bullied uh
um so Taylor has a brand new album
coming out
um October 22nd that's so cool you do
promo for her yeah yeah yeah it's so
sick I had to promote any thing it's
Taylor's album it's coming out at
midnight on October 22nd it's called
midnight it's going to be really cool
all the track names are unreleased um
but October 22nd also happens to be Kim
Kardashian's birthday oh oh wow a little
drama here but isn't it also like
significant for like other reasons it's
like she released another album her last
album on that same date or something
like that
I know I know of yeah no there's some
she did I mean there is a significance
if you do the math somewhere I don't
remember it uh it equals 13 in some way
and 13 is your favorite number that's
what it is yeah that but I don't believe
she's ever announced uh an album on the
20th okay I could be wrong no I was just
thinking it is usually October November
era but um I don't think the 22nd but
besides that
um she announced it at the VMAs exactly
13 years that's what it was yeah so she
announced at the VMAs exactly 13 years
after Kanye went up and said I'm gonna
let you finish and so many people are
like oh she's letting him live rent free
and it's like brah he created so much
trauma for her like the media hated her
for years she had to go into hiding let
the girl [ __ ] talk about it like shut
your [ __ ] mouth you're not you don't
know and still no one blames Kanye when
he's making a music video about killing
someone you know what I'm saying like I
think people are mad at Kanye now really
what do you want to say to him me yeah
I'm not mad you're mad
no I mean it's like the thing about
October 22nd and the reason that people
are like oh Petty Queen is because Kim
had a massive following and during all
that it all comes back from I don't know
which Taylor lore you guys know but I
don't know Annie so really yeah oh my
God I could go on for hours I could
start a Taylor Swift podcast Connie has
a song where he's like Taylor and I
should still have sex I made that [ __ ]
famous yeah so there's a phone call that
was recorded where he said he asked
Taylor for permission on that I vaguely
remember this yeah drunk but he never
told Taylor that line I made that [ __ ]
famous that's right
um and so however the song comes out and
Taylor's like whoa excuse me and then
Kim Kardashian is like we have the
receipts and she plays the video and
it's like cut up in some way or you know
and so it just is enough information to
show that he was on the phone with Kanye
and blah blah and so it was just crazy
like so everyone started calling Taylor
a snake and all this stuff and so like
when reputation came out she really took
a big hold of that and just turn it back
on them damn it was dope like writing
diss tracks out here yeah it really was
and a lot of people don't give
reputation enough credit because at that
era everyone hated Taylor but reputation
is genuinely a really good album and uh
there's like this one that there's a
song called This is why we don't have
nice things and or this is why we can't
have nice things and she talks about
like you have your receipts and all that
like all that stuff as a big nod at Kim
for just being wrong like she's just
wrong she just lied yeah so this is a
big slap in the face to Kim because you
know what's going to happen on October
72nd everyone's gonna be talking about
this and we're gonna talk about Kim's
birthday and apparently they're back
together Kim gagne I don't know that's
what I heard
crazy stuff no just in time for the
album yeah how do you how do you hear
that on another podcast nice yeah he
called you they said that exact same
thing so I don't know where they learned
it from but it's crazy stuff podcast if
it's true yeah yeah he came on whine
about it
all right that was awesome I saw that I
saw it I felt good when you saw that on
the dock right there you were like nah
this I could have offered mentally your
hands rubbed together like it's time you
lost like at least 20 of your viewership
because turns out a lot of people hate
Taylor
um what are you passionate about that I
would not like go-karts oh talk about it
I would love that no no please please I
would love it
let's end it everyone's tired of my
go-kart hobby I think we're in five
minutes yeah it's about timely the thing
about a shifter cart is okay so thank
you so much for joining us guys really
appreciate it Taylor Swift's new album
October 26th you can remember that